Vy Puy Bánh Mang Zigerong về Việt Nam cùng đại nhà khội Vy Puy Bánh Kê Staspa.
Không còn là tin đồ, Vy Puy Bánh đã chính thức của Bố Thung Tinh nhà băng này sẽ mang nghệ sĩ hàng đầu
Ká Póp Zigerong đến Việt Nam biểu sĩnh tại sinh bận động Mỹ định.
Hà lội ngày 21 thần sau, trong quên khổ đại nhà khội Ká Póp Vy Puy Bánh Kê Staspa.
Nếu Sĩ Zigerong cũng đã sát nhận thông tin khi tự miền trái kê vý sự kiện lên story trang mạng sở hội của anh.
Đại nhà khội đánh dấu lần tính hộ sau 12 năm của Zigerong với phát thông mộ Việt và cũng là mạnh trào sinh đầu tiên của anh trong vệ trò mỹ sĩ số lâu tại Việt Nam.
Cô Vy Zigerong, siêu tuyện di hoàn cũng sẽ góp mặt và cộng đồng cao Phan Việt Nam sẽ lần đầu tiên được tận mắt chính kiến khoảng khách hai biểu tượng sống của Ká Pó cùng đứa chung trên một sự khổ Việt.
Ngoài ra, Đại nhà khội còn có sự thân ra của DPR, END, PEM PESC và CHIPO S.
Còn ban PESC sẽ chính thức được mở từ ngày 21 tháng năm 2020.
Dên chủ thể VP-Bang PESC sẽ được hưởng quy lợi đột quyền mô về sống từ ngày 21 tháng 15 yếu đại vô cùng hóc sẫn.
Bối việc thành công mang Zigerong về Việt Nam, VP-Bang lần lưỡa hàng đường trông việc kiến thạo những giả sị tính vự tin thần trên cảm hứng tối cộng đồng.